[Music]
when people think of a Dark Horse I
think most people think of people who
were successful that nobody saw coming
right and that's technically true but in
our research we actually found that Dark
Horse's
are people who prioritize personal
fulfillment over conventional notions of
success and that priority is what
actually puts them on a very individual
path but it's also ultimately what
allows them to be both successful and
happy and I think those lessons end up
being valuable to anybody who wants to
live a more fulfilling life the origins
of this Dark Horse are a little bit
personal right so I'm a Harvard
professor today but I also was a high
school dropout with a 0.9 GPA ended up
getting married right out of high school
had two kids by the time I was 21 and we
ended up working a string of
minimum-wage jobs and was actually on
welfare for a little while
so my future was sort of bleak and I
felt a bit lost and it was actually my
dad who gave me this piece of advice
that changed everything so he said if I
wanted something better I needed to
figure out what truly motivated me and
stay really close to that the rest of my
life he felt like that was gonna be
important for me being able to achieve
what I could what I could and that piece
of advice could put me on a completely
different path that led me to get a GED
then eventually to college and then
ultimately to Harvard where I've spent
the last decade getting to study what
makes people tick and so for me Dark
Horse is kind of like the culmination of
a lot of things that I care about
because when I think about how we can
use these insights from the science that
are part of another things I think
helping people live more fulfilling
lives is probably right at the top of
the list I think most folks feel like
like they should know what motivates
them but like actually I think we're
constantly surprised right we make
choices there were like I don't really
like what I'm doing and like but you
thought you would so obviously you don't
you know know what motivates you but
like I think there's a there's kind of a
for me there's almost like this
laddering of like how we get to this
like how do you end up pursuing a
fulfilling life right and I
knowing what motivates you is like core
to that right it's not everything but if
you don't truly know what matters most
to you and what really drives you is
really no chance of having a
consistently fulfilling life you might
be successful with some stuff but you
probably be successfully unhappy and so
the the interesting thing about it
there's two things that I think are
really fascinating the Dark Horse's
taught us that are different than the
way most of us think about things
so first is even how we define who we
are right because I think self-knowledge
is this vital thing and most of us when
we talk about who we are we tend to
think about things like what we're good
at or what job we do right Dark Horse is
right off the bat they'll talk about the
things that motivate them the things
that matter most to them and they build
their identity off of that so to the
question of then of like if if knowing
what motivates you is so important like
like why do we struggle to figure that
out and like how could we get better at
that so I think that the biggest
challenge with the motivation aspect is
that when we tend to think about what
motivates us we tend to look at what
society tells us we all should be
motivated by right if you think about if
you just look outward you realize
there's some big things some Universal
things like competition
you know money collaboration or anyway
stuff that we kind of all feel like
affects us in some way but what we found
is like look the truth is human beings
are just more complicated than that so
all of us are motivated by a wide range
of things some of them are those big
universals but what we found is that
there's also a whole bunch of very
specific things that tend to be
particularly you as an individual right
so for example in in the Dark Horse
project we actually talked to people who
were genuinely motivated by specific
things like organizing people's closets
like genuinely motivated I can't
understand that for the life of me it
has zero motivational Homebush but or
aligning physical objects with your
hands like truly motivating right these
are so specific they probably don't
matter to very many people but they met
her deeply to these individuals and what
courses taught us is that when it comes
to living a fulfilling life those
specific motives are every bit as
important as the big general ones right
so the question of okay well how do I
figure out those specific ones there's a
pretty straightforward way to get
started and it seems simple but it's
worth trying is if you just think about
some of the things you enjoy doing right
and ask yourself why I'm again this
seems simple but like if you say like I
enjoy football right but it's easy to
confuse the thing you enjoy with what
motivates you I'm not motivated by
football I just enjoy that activity
right I enjoy watching it but then I ask
like is it the competition is it that
it's a team sport that requires
collaboration and coordination is that
there's a strategy element to it you
know is it playing outdoors right and
the more you can sort of dissect that
and answer those questions you start to
get a sense for what really motivates
you right and if you ask yourself that
question often enough it will pretty
quickly reveal those are a breadth of
your motives and that can put you on a
path to a fulfilling life and why this
is important is most people would stop
it like I can tell you the things I like
to do right or I can tell you that I
like my job right now but I can't
actually tell you why and so you get
locked into like I'm a football guy
right well now if I can't play football
anymore which I definitely can't right
um what do I do
right I suddenly have this crisis of
like I don't know who I am I don't know
what but if you understood that like the
reason you enjoyed football were these
four or five things those those travel
well right you can actually look for
other things to do that check those
boxes
that will turn out to be every bit as
fulfilling to you and dark horses are
really good at that that's like knowing
deeply this breadth of motives they have
and then be able to make decisions off
of them
[Music]